bonsoir nous débutons cette édition du 7
8 ce du 4 avril depuis paris depuis le
sénat les sénateurs qui débute tout
juste l'examen du projet de loi
autorisant le mariage pour tous nous
allons aller à la rencontre de gérard
larcher il est à sénateur ump des
yvelines ancien président du sénat y va
nous recevoir nous donner son sentiment
ce sera juste après ce premier point sur
les titres du jour
aujourd'hui dans l'actu des citoyens sur
ay leur quartier pour value à plaisir
les locataires patrouille dans la cité
afin de traquer les incivilités que
faire des balles de tennis usagées au
lieu de les jeter à la poubelle six
dernières kafka seront recyclés et
servir de nouveaux matériaux pour
réaliser des terrains sportifs mais
adapté bilan de l'opération à l'aller
décision de kelis avoir 14 ans et fonder
sa propre entreprise c'est possible le
concept de la mini entreprise a été
créée dans les années 20 aux états unis
et s'est ensuite exportée en europe des
classes de 3e sont invités à y
participer
exemple au collège descartes de fontenay
le fleury
championnat régional de boxe éducative à
la verrière le muriautin luca faivre a
remporté son match entre angles
aujourd'hui 4 avril débute donc l'examen
de ce projet de loi autorisant le
mariage pour tous examen du projet de
loi au sénat bonsoir gérard larcher
merci de nous recevoir ici donc au sénat
dans votre bureau qu'attendez-vous des
discussions qui s'ouvrent au sénat
d'abord que le sénat soit lui-même
c'est-à-dire a lieu où on puisse
s'exprimer librement
sereinement et en même temps d'aller au
fond des choses parce que naturellement
ce texte tel qu'il est issu des travaux
de l'assemblée nationale tel qu'il est
issu des travaux de notre commission qui
d'ailleurs je le reconnais a largement
auditionné chacun des groupes politiques
a aussi auditionné je pense à mon groupe
l'ump est que nous puissions donc avoir
ce débat en allant au fond des choses
pas simplement des ans des postures
parce qu'au fond c'est quoi c'est le
bouleversement d'une institution qui
dans la république s'appelle la famille
tels que on la conçoit avec un élément
majeur qu'est la construction d'un
filiation et sur ce sujet là je crois
qu'on doit avoir un débat a eu au fond
est ce qu'on peut avoir un débat serein
pour autant parce que là c'est le climat
est particulièrement tendue les
opposants qui durcissent aussi elles
disent qu il n'y a pas que j'allais dire
le débat autour du mariage il ya aussi
un environnement politique qu'on ne peut
pas ignorer environnement immédiat sur
le crédit ou le discrédit de la parole
politique environnement aussi médias
quant à un moment on parle j'allais dire
de bouleverser la politique familiale
mise en place par le général de gaulle
je pense à la réflexion sur les
allocations familiales je passe à la
réflexion aussi sur par exemple le
soutien aux emplois familiaux je pense
au quotient familial dans la fiscalité
et nos concitoyens ont le sentiment tout
ça qui construisait un pays qui avait
une vraie politique familiale est en
train j'allais lire 2 de s'effondrer de
disparaître sous les coups de boutoir
j'allais dire d'une certaine modernité
entre guillemets de la société et sous
les coups de boutoir de la crise et il
faut pas s'étonner qu'il y ait des
réactions fortes et des réactions
d'ailleurs qui dépasse les clivages
politiques ou spirituelle et donc nous
le pensions moi je pense qu'il faut
renvoyer au référendum voilà pourquoi je
soutiendrai
tout début de la discussion du texte le
renvoi au référendum la motion
référendaire que bruno retailleau
présentera au nom du groupe auquel
j'appartiens si finalement il n'ya pas
recours au référendum que le sénat doit
se prononcer ce que le sénat peut
rejeter ce texte le cdh ap le rejeter
c'est là où je souhaite qu'un débat est
au fond et dépasse j'allais dire dans
notre groupe à l'ump il ya par principe
aucune consigne de vote la liberté de
vote est totale je souhaite que dans la
majorité parce que j'entends aussi des
collègues sur ces sujets là et bien que
la liberté puisse permette au sénat soit
d'amender en profondeur par exemple la
question du contrat d'union civile et un
pour les personnes de même sexe n'est
pas illégitime elle est posée je
souhaite que nous progressions dans ce
débat mais en même temps la question
fondamentale famille filiation et en
filigrane derrière gestation pour autrui
procréation médicalement assistée des
questions d'éthique quoi qu'en ait dit
le président de la république
est bien toutes ces questions là vont
être présente et si nous n'arrivions pas
j'allais dire à un texte qui puisse
répondre aux préoccupations largement
exprimée ce texte ordre à l'assemblée
nationale mais nous allons préparer tout
au long de ce débat voilà pourquoi la
tonalité 5 sans doute différente au
sénat par rapport à l'assemblée
nationale nous allons préparer un
éventuel recours au conseil
constitutionnel car je suis de ceux qui
avec patrice gélard avec bruno
retailleau avec beaucoup de
parlementaires considérons qu'il y a pas
respect de la constitution dans ses
fondamentaux notamment de la
constitution de 46 qui est repris dans
le préambule de l'accord sitution 1958
j'évoquais tout à l'heure le climat on
peut citer aussi le cas dans les
yvelines où le député binet a été dû
être évacuées de l'université de
versailles saint quentin où se tenait
une conférence puisque les manifestants
sont venus envahir l'amphithéâtre où ils
échanger avec des étudiants ce sont des
attitudes des comportements que vous
acceptez que vous cautionnez que vous
une précieuse naturellement jamais la
violence par principe et dans la
démocratie celle des bas mais il faut
qu'on écoute aussi les gens qui étaient
dans la rue et j'ai le sentiment moi
personnellement qu'on ne les écoute pas
qu'on ne les entend pas et qu'ils
auraient moins droit au respect de
l'autre et je pense que faut être très
attentif je sens monter je sentais une
ambiance qui m'inquiète une ambiance qui
m'inquiète et cette ambiance qui
m'inquiète elle est naturellement
potentialiser par les événements récents
et je pense ce qui s'est passé à 48
heures autour j'allais dire des aveux de
jérôme cahuzac parce qu'il faut bien les
appeler comme ça le discrédit de la
parole politique ça peut changer la
donne sur le débat du mariage pour tous
les phares avant cette affaire qu'est ce
qu'un avis la parole politique ça nous
touche tous et j'allais dire la
république irréprochable est passé
j'allais dire dans un cul de basse fosse
et donc par rapport à ça je crois que
c'est le moment pour la parole politique
de reprendre crédit et de nous écouter
les uns les autres ces derniers jours
vous avez jugé l'action de votre
successeur à la tête du sénat jean
pierre bel pour vous il ne fait pas
fonctionner correctement le sénat je
rappelle que vous avez été président de
2008 à 2011 est très clair qu'elles
contiennent quelques-uns de coria les
draps un conflit du tout personnel
puisque nous nous respectons
mutuellement ce que je constate au sénat
c'est qu'il n'y a plus aucun grand texte
qui est voté
on a voté ni le projet de loi de
finances ni le projet de loi de
financement de sécurité sociale et si le
groupe d'opposition ump n'avait pas mis
hier une proposition de résolution sur
un projet d'acte 3 décentralisation qui
était totalement j'allais dire fou eh
bien je ne suis pas sûr que le premier
ministre hier ne serait pas serait venu
pour retirer un texte aussi pas sûr donc
ici au sénat il faut que le sénat
s'exprime avec son autonomie le sénat
n'a pas être alignés savez j'ai vécu y
compris sous le quinquennat de nicolas
sarkozy que je soutenais des moments
difficiles où il n'était pas en accord
ça a été connue tous sur la laïcité
sur des questions aussi de société avec
le président que je soutenais j'ai
toujours tenu à la ligne de tram et du
sénat je fais vraiment que cette
autonomie on la retrouve dans ce débat
que ce soit dans le débat pour le
mariage pour tous ou demain dans le
débat que nous aurons peut-être je ne
sais plus très bien sûr un acte iii de
la décentralisation c'est le conseil que
vous pourriez me donner avec ses
partenaires au cinéma que je constate
c'est que la maison ne marche pas très
bien merci gérard larcher vous restez
encore avec nous quelques instants on
fait une petite pause pour faire le tour
de l'actualité locale comme chaque soir
dans le 7 8 et puis on se retrouve juste
après toujours en compagnie de gérard
larcher pour évoquer la question des
municipal à présent
le loup
de même de chou
défilé de volontaires à la ligue des
yvelines de tennis pour chargées dans le
camion de la société coved spécialisée
dans le traitement et la valorisation
des déchets cinquante six mille balles
usagées des balles récoltés depuis le
mois de novembre dans près de 120 clubs
du département pour l'opération balle
jaune lancé par la fédération française
de tennis
ça fait trois ans que on suit en suisse
cette opération et on a de plus en plus
d'adhérents qui spontanément viennent
nous apporter leurs balles usagées pour
la bonne cause la bonne cause le
recyclage des balles jaunes plutôt que
de finir en jouets pour chiens ou
incinérés dans le circuit traditionnel
des déchets leur seconde vie ça va être
d'être utile à nouveau c'est à dire de
d'être broyé d'être transformée pour
devenir en fait des granulats de
caoutchouc que l'on va séparer de la
feutrine et qui vont servir mélangé à de
la résine de polyuréthane à refaire des
surfaces de sports qui vont permettre de
faire de la rééducation motrice pour les
polyhandicapés de faire des terrains de
sport adapté et d'être en fait des
surfaces qui amortissent en fait le choc
six structures en ile de france ont
accueilli un sol de balle jaune recyclés
comme la maison de marie à poissy un
centre de rééducation de jeunes adultes
polyhandicapés ou une aire de 162 mètres
carrés a été installée en extérieur pour
cette année la ligue des yvelines de
tennis n'a pas encore déterminé quel
établissement bénéficiera de l'opération